we're at a critical stage here
you're gonna die
pretty soon today we're watching family
by the time i'm not gonna lie not a huge
fan of the title but let's see what the
show has to offer and learn something
along in the process let's get started
i was just eating till i'm dead
probably a normal day for me is wake up
around 12 figure out something i'm gonna
eat immediately
tv video games bed
so it's interesting you see him drying
himself off with the towel in that
specific way when you have excess of
body weight and you have excess skin
excess fat tissue you have to be really
thorough about drying yourself because
it's really easy for a candida infection
to begin and as a result you can get
really bad redness irritation of the
skin it can then become a full on
cellulitis where bacterial infection
sets in so it's really important to dry
skin folds in order to decrease the
likelihood of this happening i never
would have thought at 34 i'd be living
with my father
and i'd be
have no job have no real money and just
be playing video games all day and
eating when you're trying to address
someone's situation where they're
morbidly obese you have to look at the
patient as a whole you have to look at
what are the reasons uh that contributed
to this occurring what can you do in
order to prevent it from recurring look
at triggers look at mental health
factors look at sleep schedules daily
activities like in general i'm not
against gaming i love gaming i consider
myself a gamer but there are times when
we can take something that can be
potentially beneficial and make it into
something that it's not and this can
happen with anything i mean it's really
the dose decides to poison so having an
unhealthy relationship with food with
gaming all of this can contribute to
this ultimate unhealthy lifestyle which
will ultimately decrease lifespan and
decrease quality of life and that
quality of life is really what i like to
focus on because yes we want to extend
lifespan we want patients to live a long
life but at the same time i want them to
live that life comfortably i don't want
them to be in pain i don't want them to
be in mental anguish because they don't
feel like they're connecting with the
outside world and that's what a good
doctor nutritionist or like i said any
other health professional looks at when
addressing these types of problems
okay he'll tell me what to get him and
i'll come right back a lot of times in
case that's too much food but i'll get
it for him and bring it to the house and
put it right in front of him i don't
want to call him an enabler but i mean
sometimes that's really the way like it
seems that it is
i'm not buying the groceries i'm not
buying the frozen pizzas i'm not buying
the chicken wings
there's someone facilitating the food
coming in and it's not me i mean there's
partial truth in that i don't think
that's a valid excuse for someone to
make if my patient told me hey look it's
not about me it's not i'm not the one
doing the shopping at the end of the day
there's a level of personal
responsibility involved in all this but
to solely place the blame at the foot of
others is not a healthy pattern not
because it's right or wrong but because
it it takes away control from you and
when you take away control from you you
actually create more of a problem where
you feel like you're helpless you have
to do it and there's nothing you can do
to change it when that is not in fact
reality there are things you can do to
change it there are conversations to be
had with your quote unquote enablers
because the foods that
are being consumed are a unhealthy foods
b there's salt being added to already
very salty foods the portion sizes are
tremendous and i i saw the father
mention tea that tea has so much excess
calories from the added refined sugars
like that's even worse than eating a
huge amount of food because at least
when you eat the food you can feel
satiated there's some fiber and other
nutrients in there but when you're just
drinking sugar water which is
essentially what a lot of these sweet
teas are in mega amounts you're just
adding weight
so i made it outside this trough
currently because
i cannot physically bathe in a sit-down
bathtub or stand-up shower area
because i'm a bigger guy with like folds
and flaps and i have to move around like
almost like a pig in a way and wallow
and roll over to get like the back of my
leg i have to lift up literal like
pieces of skin it's just a super
difficult process there's a lot of
adjustments that are needed to be made
in someone's home when they are of this
excessive weight there's also
adjustments that need to be made in the
hospital i've had patients
who are morbidly obese who unfortunately
did not fit in our cat scan machines in
our mri machines and the nose scenarios
a you try and look at the facilities
around you if there's an option to
transfer the patient that someone does
have
a larger piece of equipment and then
there's sometimes been situations where
we literally have to contact our local
zoo who have really large machinery for
some of their larger animals and we use
those it's not a pleasant conversation
to have with patients but it goes to
show how
there's a lot that needs to be done in
order to make sure that we're keeping
folks like this healthy
this is the icebreaker we do have to
take your weight first this is coming
when i wear myself in my house i do it
butt naked just use the bathroom number
one number two
and i've like tried to throw up the last
meal i ate so i can lose any pounds
now i'm there wearing clothes i'm
kicking off my flip-flops anything i can
get off of my body to lower the number
because i know it's going to be
shockingly big
it's
711.8 now i know some bariatric offices
that try and save this step for later in
the visit reason being is whether this
patient is approximately 500 600 700
pounds we know that there's going to be
a benefit to doing the procedure so we
can already lead with that assumption a
lot of times it's traumatic to step on
this scale and look at the number so we
try and perhaps save it for not the
first first thing you do when you walk
into the office because that alone can
cause people to not want to come in to
see the doctor in the first place we're
at a critical stage here
you're gonna die
pretty soon
unless something happens here now i know
that's jarring to here
i understand why
i agree with this approach i think this
is the most successful approach because
it's honest whether you have a patient
who's morbidly obese and is over 700
pounds
or you're recommending a do not
resuscitate order for a family member
those are difficult conversations the
truest most honest
non-judgmental way you could deliver
that news is gonna be the most
successful way you could deliver that
news with you
the route we're gonna go down towards is
a sleeve gastrectomy okay all right
so
this is your stomach you got you all
right what we're going to do is we're
going to go in
and we're going to remove this outer
portion of your stomach right here
there will be a metabolic switch that
gets flipped in your body when you have
this surgery your body will want to lose
weight when dr proctor was going over to
surgery it was pretty scary only because
i fear surgery in general understandable
that he's apprehensive surgery comes
with legitimate legitimate risks even if
it's bariatric surgery that being said
being 700 plus pounds carries way more
risks than the surgery and that's how we
decide whether or not a procedure a
medication a treatment is good for a
patient why don't you tell me what does
a normal day of eating look like for you
prior to when you saw doctor proctor
like we're waking up at like 12 okay um
and then probably ordering food from the
hot dog house what do you usually order
on like a normal day it might be like 20
wings or like 10 tenders and then it
would be like a small order of tater
tots and a large sweet tea this size
yeah yeah okay so we're doing 32 ounces
of sweet tea my lunches were either taco
salad or like tacos but it was you know
not a lot of sour cream and then were
you having dinner it could be anything
from like a big thing of fried chicken
or pizza we'd have like not occasionally
but sometimes so dr proctor wants you to
lose 60 pounds by the time he sees you
next the reason why all of these
guidelines are in place about having
patients lose a certain amount of weight
before the surgery having them see a
psychologist
running blood tests is you want to set
the patient up for success if we just
willy-nilly did bariatric surgeries on
everybody who is obese
it would be problematic because what
happens is when you do the surgery
there's very specific protocol you have
to follow if you over eat with a smaller
stomach you can actually cause surgical
issues you can rupture your stomach you
can cause vomiting it can cause mental
havoc it can lead you to going into a
dark depression we really try and select
our patients that we think are going to
have the best outcome from the bariatric
surgery instead of just recommending it
for all so i've hired a personal trainer
for the first time in my life
this is the first time i've been to the
gym in a long time and i am a little bit
nervous hey what's up man casey right
yeah yeah dex yes sir how you doing when
i watch programs like this on tlc my one
issue that i have is this is a lot of
this is not reality for most americans i
don't want someone who is potentially
wanting to lose weight to look at this
and think that unless i have this
i can't lose weight it's not true you
don't need the diesel personal trainer
in order to lose the weight any kind of
physical activity when you're going from
zero will help also being kind to
yourself and not pushing yourself too
hard in the beginning is also really
important with someone who is 700 plus
pounds you really want to make sure that
you're focusing on injury prevention
it's very easy to overload joints to
pull and hurt muscles and as a result
you can set someone back so it's really
about starting slow gonna do your arm
rotation
all right you got you
good then we go back the opposite way
all right
i had casey move his own body weight so
he can establish a correlation
between
what he's accomplished already and what
he can expect himself to do in the
future see like someone might look at
that and say that's not exercise yes it
is his heart rate's going up his
breathing rate's going up this all
automatically kicks up the metabolism
helps him prepare to meet the challenge
and he's been sedentary you can't push
too hard too fast you can put too much
strain on the heart and even cause a
heart attack there's actually a type of
heart attack called a type two
myocardial infarction that happens as a
result of not a pure blockage but simply
because there was so much strain on the
heart that there wasn't enough
circulation going that actual damage has
occurred it's been three months since my
surgery and i feel good
little things are changing in me that i
didn't really
expect to change so quickly as i
accomplish more
my self-esteem is rising so i feel like
i can do more so it's just a good
[Music]
[Applause]
i feeling this journey at 711 pounds and
today i'm happy to say that i'm 525. i
think it's great when you start seeing
your goals pan out and that's how
motivation happens it's seeing your hard
work be paid off and it might not happen
off the first second or third time but
as you continue you keep seeing that
you're making improvements whether it's
after a week after a month or after a
year and even for myself i had a buddy
that was in the icu recently and had a
lot of neurological deficits and as he
was slowly recovering he would call me
each day upset the fact that he wasn't
making progress and i had to remind him
write down what your deficits are today
do it next week do it the following week
and then each time you're upset look
back and see how much you've improved
when you look in every hour by hour day
by day sometimes it's easy to lose sight
of how much you've accomplished but when
you really spread it out and think and
scale which we as humans are not good at
doing you get to see the accomplishment
you get to feel motivated you get to see
that you're making moves in the right
direction even if it's three steps
forward one step back well i'm trying to
get my license removed this is him now
because on my other license i'm huge
i'm a whale
so there we go that's me
i don't know if you can see that real
well i don't know but that's me it's
really weird too because like
2020 corona is like the worst year of
some people's lives like it's really
been awful for people but like
it's gonna go down in the record books
is like one of the best years of my life
probably life for me is blossoming
what's he's experiencing right now is
almost like a form of post-traumatic
growth it's looking back at your
accomplishments there's nostalgia there
and the fact that he's in fact reached
his goal he's in fact improved his
quality of life it goes to show that
everything that we discussed in the
beginning of this episode when it comes
to extending life and improving quality
of life he's a walking testimonial for
really proud of him check out this video
of me taking a career test do you think
i got doctor or something else as always
stay happy and healthy compose or
arrange music i have no creativity in my
body so if you ask me to draw you
something compose you something it's
gonna come out looking like the trapped
version of the happy birthday song